Herkese merhabalar ben Kadircan kırkoyun
bugün beni çok heyecanlandıran bir konu
üstünde paylaşmak istiyorum Hatta ben
çok hareketliyimdir Umarım bu yuvarlağa
Dışarı çıkmam Yarın teknoloji
girişimcileri yani başka bir deyişle
Aslında toplumu dönüştürenler
diyebiliriz yarının teknoloji
girişimcileri beni çok heyecanlandıran
Bir konu bu yüzden yani son 24
yaşındayım öbürünün son 8 yılını verdim
bugün hafta size ondan bahsedeceğim
Yarın teknolojik gelişimciliğini nasıl
odaklanırız Aslında onları yetiştirmek
de yani nasıl yetiştirmemiz lazım Yarın
liderlerle nasıl yetiştireceğiz eğitimle
o yüzden aslında biraz konuya eğitimle
başlamak istiyorum Müsaadenizle
eğitimin biraz tarihçesine gidelim şimdi
8 Yüzyıl solda gördüğünüz eğitim modeli
aslında Bir sınıf var bir hoca var
öğrenciler oturuyor ve dinliyor 13
yüzyıla geliyoruz yine aynı bir hoca var
dinleyen var yine aynı şekilde bir
eğitim modeli var bir bilgi aktarım var
tabi dersi aradan yıllar geçiyor
yüzyıllar geçiyor Tabi bu süreçte
kültürümüzde Ahilik ustalık Usta Çırak
modelleri bugünkü adıyla yeni yeni hafta
birçok eğitim modeli deniyor ve Bence
başarılı oluyor aradan geçen yıllara
baktığımızda 19 yüzyılda bakın 100
yıllar geçtik sanayi devrimi diye bir
şey oluyor Dünya'da üretim değişiyor
ekonomik Paradigma değişiyor toplumda
Hepsi bir anda değişmeye başlıyor Tabi
ki toplumu yetiştiren kavram sistem
eğitim olunca eğitimde değişiyor 19
yüzyılların ihtiyaçlarına yönelik bir
eğitim sistemi Tabii ki ortaya
[Müzik]
Peki değişebiliyor mu bugüne
geldiğimizde hepimiz yine bir hoca var
dinliyoruz ve bilgi aktarımı oluyor Ama
internette var ama artık Bu değişmeye
başladı
dünyaya ekonomik forumu diyor ki ben çok
özet geçeceğim
2025'te Öyle yetkinlikler ihtiyaç
duyulacak ki bunlara sahip değilsen
işsiz kalacaksın Ne bu yetkinlikler çok
iyi matematiğin olması mı değil çok iyi
İngilizce konuşmak mı değil ne Bunlar
etkili iletişim stratejik düşünme
eleştirsel düşünme ekip çalışması gibi
hasta birazdan yetkinlik kavramlarını
artık toplum iş dünyası ihtiyaç duyuyor
ama ne kadar karşılayabiliriz bugünkü
eğitim sistemine soru işareti
Üstüne bir de koyup gelmedi mi İyice
dijitalleşmenin içine girdik ama eğitim
sistemi gene aynı böyle Zuma kaydık ama
yine bir hoca anlatıyor bu sefer yüzde
ne dinlemeye başlıyoruz ama aslında yine
bir şey değişmiyor doğrudan eğitimle Bu
da aslında burada büyük bir açığın büyük
bir yine bir model değişikliğin olduğunu
en büyük göstergesi Peki
konuyu biraz daha kendi hikayeme
bağlamak istiyorum şu anda bugün
konuşurken 24 yaşındayım Aslında klasik
bir Türk genciyim devlet bursları
büyüdüm klasik bilgisayar internet
devrin içinde doğduk bütün gün oyun
oynadık arkadaşlarımız işte çeşitli
oyunlar oynadık level kastık işte liseye
geçtik Ondan sonra internet bağımlısı
olarak adlandırıldık kimilerince gibi
klasik bir Türk genciyim Aslında
hepinizle aynıyım
derken bu işlere girdik 8 sınıfta 7
sınıfta Hani Klasik Türk genci gibi
böyle oyunlar oynuyordum benim Ama şöyle
bir huyum var ya ben çok şeyim hızlı
Hani kolay bir yolu bulma kafasında
mesela biriyle tanışacak mıyım hemen
kafa yani bana yeter ki Hedef gösterin
bir şey yapılacak mı Bana Hedef gösterin
çözüyorum yine bu yazılımla alakalı
derken bir şekilde yazılım öğrenme
belasını bulaştık ardından da bu işlere
girmiş olduk
bugünün şartlarına Aslında YouTube diye
bir platform var yani bilmeyenlerimiz
yoktur Hatta birçok kişi Bu sunumu
YouTube'dan dinliyor olacak YouTube
Aslında dünyanın en büyük Eğitim
Platformu yani senford'daki işte
marketteki dünyanın en iyi
üniversitelerdeki hocalarında dersine
erişebiliyorsunuz Ben bir şey biliyorum
bunu anlatmak istiyorum diyen insanların
da aslında bilgisine tek tıkla
ulaşabiliyorsunuz Ben de kendimde
yazılım Aslında YouTube'dan öğrendim
benim olmayan İngilizcem de aslında baka
baka yapa yapa öğrendim diyebilirim
sonra ama bunu yaptığım şey 7 8
sınıftaydım
o dönemde işte ülkemizde tabletler
dağıtıldı dağıtılma projesi ortaya çıktı
bazı okullarda pilot yapıldı akıl
tahtalar kuruldu bize her genç gibi Abi
bize tablet ne zaman gelecek işte gelsin
de artık eğitim tablete geçsin
dijitalleşelim işte bıktık şu
kitaplardan gibi gibi gibi Ondan sonra
şunu düşündüm ya çok güzel tabletler
geliyor akıllı tahtalar geliyor cihaz
hazır Peki içerik ne olacak Bunda Biz
neye tıklayacağız hani var olan kitabın
500 sayfa kitabın pdfini Alıp ona sadece
kaydım mı yapacağız Yoksa farklı bir şey
mi olacak derken aslında bir niyetlendik
biz bir şey yapalım dedik hani böyle
yazılımı öğrendik ki bir şeyler yapalım
dedik
o zaman da ortaokul Sondayım iki satır
kod yani hani sunum gibi düşünün birinci
sayfayı kapat 2 sayfayı aç sunumu tabiri
yazısı bir arayüz yaptım bu arayüzde de
Atatürk'ün hayatı dedik adına dedim yani
tıklıyorsunuz ailesini tanıyorsunuz
tıklıyorsunuz eğitim hayatını
tanıyorsunuz tıklıyorsunuz örnek
veriyorum inkılaplarını tanıyorsunuz
gibi gibi aslında bir içerik uygulaması
yaptım
ondan sonra böyle link olarak oluşturup
bir yerden attık Tabii o zamanlar Google
Play App Store yok zaten masaüstü
bilgisayar programıydı 2500-3000 kişi
indirdi beni böyle bir heyecanlandırdı
Ama şöyle bir problem vardı Benim
hafızam çok kötü isimlere tutamam Hatta
o yüzden herkese abi abla derim Hani
ismini unuttuğum çaktırmamak için sonra
ezberim çok zayıftır gibi böyle
unutkanlıkla hafıza ile alakalı
problemim var Ben bunu biliyorum dedim
ki ya Yazım öğrendik de biz zaten iki
satır kod yazıyoruz şimdi Yazım öğrendim
deme bir kere yazın böyle büyük projeler
yapmak istiyorsun abi adam var bu iş
için 4 yıl üniversite okuyor yıllar
çalışıyor ancak bir şeyler yapabiliyor
Ben kimim ki daha ortaokul lise
öğrencisiyim gideceğim Yazım öğreneceğim
bütün kodları ezberleyeceğim olmayan
hafızamlar Ondan sonra bir şeyler
yapacağım dedim ki bu iş bana göre değil
dijital iyi hoş da hani yazılım mı bana
göre değil deyip aslında bir
bıraktın kabiliyetsiz gittin Photoshop
öğrendim İşte temel tasarım falan
öğrendim bugünkü adıyla dijital
pazarlama öğrenmiş hali uğraştık
internette ilk paramı kazandım benim
için ondan sonra derken böyle bir belayı
bulaştık
Ondan sonra lise 2'ye geçtim de lise 3'e
geçerken internette bir haber gördüm
Tugay dev arkadaş Edirne'de yine bir
deli Lisesi bir kulüp kuruyor kendi
öğrendiği yazılımı arkadaşlara öğretiyor
20-25 kişilik grup Oo dedim süper Hani
niye bizde olmasın bende arkadaşlarına
bir şeyler öğreteyim bizde bir şeyler
yapalım diye Aslında tüm ailelerden
Facebook'tan o zamanlar Instagram yok
Facebook ile tanışın derken ben de bir
şey yapmak istiyorum Burada derken en
sonunda kendi listemde böyle bir şey
niyetlendim arkadaşlar topladım yazın
bilmiyorum dedim biz öğreneceğiz beraber
Pazartesi okuldan sonra kalacağız örnek
veriyorum pazar akşam oturup çalışıyorum
pazartesi öğretiyorum birevim kendimi
zorlaya zorluyor öğretirken öğrendiğim
bir süreç oldu o süreçte uğraştık
okuldan sonra kaldık 40 küsür
arkadaşımızdı ama ondan sonra işte
Bürokrasi Okulu derken iş kaldı
problemler diyeyim çok detaya girmeden
ondan sonra bu iş benim hoşuma gitti
çünkü hem birlikte üretmek hem de bu
arkadaşların yapabildiğini görmek Evet
yani benim lise daha önce yazın
bilmiyordu geldi Yazım yaptı Bu işlem
para kazanacak seviyeye geldi Tamam
güzel bunu ölçek değilim Ben de biraz
hani böyle ülke kalkındıralım işte
milliyetçi ruhsal hareket eden bir
insanım dedim ki Hadi bunu daha çok
yapalım daha çok kişiye dokunalım ama
yani Yüzde eğitimle 40 kişiye dokunduk
bunu 40 bine 100 eğitimle yapamayız
farklı bir şey lazım 40.000 yapmamız
lazım 400.000 yapmamız lazım 4 milyon
yapmamız lazım memlekette 16-18 milyon
aktif Hani bizim hedeflediğimiz bir yaş
kitle var Buna 100 eğitimle nereye
ulaşacağız derken böyle bir kaşıntı
tuttu
Burada da şuna odaklandık dedim ki çok
güzel hani biz bir şey öğretmek
istiyoruz ama kitap yazsak hocamlarım
kitap yazar kitap haline tutun Ama
gençler Kitap okumuyor Gençler işte
YouTube'dan videoyu izlemiyor zaten
YouTube'da bir sürü şey var bir sürü
kurs var Farklı bir şey lazım onları
sevdiği bir şey lazım dedim Ondan sonra
kendinden yola çıktım ben hedef kitlenin
kendisiydim Ben neyi seviyorum dedim ne
oynamayı seviyorum savaş oyunları futbol
oyunları eminim ki buradaki oyun oynayan
birçok kişi aslında bu iki tipte oyun
oynuyorlar o zaman dedim bunlarla
kodlama öğretelim diyerek böyle bir
kaşığını tuttu bu fikirden Tabii bu
fikir değişti değişti değişti bu
anlattığım En son dediğini anlatmaya
sürülen
ilgi alanlarına göre kodlama eğitimi
Yani herkesin farklı bilgi alanı var o
zaman herkesin ilgi alanına göre farklı
metotlarla kodlama öğretelim
örnek olarak savaş senaryomuz olsun
Savaşçıları
gelsin
saldırıyı savaşmak için kod yazalım
futbol severlerimiz olsun teknik
direktöriz gol atmak için kod yazalım
gibi gibi Aslında oyun oynayarak öğreten
bir iş çıkardık
bunu yaptığınızda lise 3D 23 Nisan
2016'da yayına aldık Hatta dedik ki 25
Nisan önemli bir gün bugün de çıkaralım
Tabi biz bunu yaptığınızda
girişimcilikmiş Start 65 yatırılmış
hiçbir şey bilmiyorsak Klasik Türk
genciyiz çok açık bir şekilde söylüyorum
Hiçbir şey bilmiyoruz yapıp öğreniyoruz
kafamızı vura vura
yayını aldık diyorlar ki siz
girişimcisiniz
Tamam biz girişimciyiz biz böyle
girişimci olduk hani biz böyle girişimci
olalım diye yola çıkmadık nasıl
girişimci olduk bu uygulama 450.000
kişiye ulaştı 3 yılda 0 bütçeyle Hatta
apple'a geç çıktım çünkü Apple verecek
99 dolarımız yoktu yıl kodu hazır
olmasına rağmen gibi yani böyle sıfır
bütçeyle çıkan bir süreçten bahsediyoruz
bu 450.000 kullanıcıya ulaşmak bize
Almanya'da Amerika'da Türkiye'de
dünyanın en iyi girişim programlarına
katılma imkanı sağladı bir sürü abimize
ablamızla tanışıp onlardan çok şey
öğrendik her yeri burnunu soktuk ne
kadar eğitim varsa ne kadar akıl hocası
varsa ne kadar kurum varsa hepsini
Tanıştık böyle kafamızı vura vura bu işi
Aslında büyütmeye Çalışacak bu süreçte
uluslararası ödüller aldık Türkiye'de en
iyi Türkiye'nin en iyi sağ tarafta
seçildik gibi Aslında 16-18 yaşlarında
ben çok net biliyorum her yeri Burası
soktuk Aslında yaptığınız oydu ve bu
sürece asla öğrenme olarak geçirdik
sonra bu iş başarısı oldu yani çünkü
satış yapamadık iş modeline oturtamadık
Hani kullanıcıya ulaştık ama hani biz
diyorduk kullanıcıya ulaşan bir şekilde
para kazanırız Öyle olmuyormuş sahada
gördük gibi gibi aslında bir sürü
sebepten bu işi battı Tabi bu süreci
bizimle birlikte başlayan birçok
yaşadığımızda vardı kendi işlerini yapan
onların da aslında çeşitli problemlerle
projesi falan oldu büyüyen oldu şeyi
gördük bu süreçte Genç girişimden nerede
problem yaşıyor paraya ulaşamıyor
müşteri ulaşamıyor akıl hocasına
ulaşamıyor doğru ekibi arkadaşlarını
bulamıyor ne yapacağını bilmiyor Her
şeyi bizzat yaşayarak gördük Hani
dinlemedik birilerini bizzat yaşadık o
zaman dedik biz bu deneyimden öğrenelim
Bu deneyimden öğrendiğimizi bir model
haline getirelim bunu da ülkemizin
gençlerini açalım
direkt sesli verelim çok kısa dünyada
girişimler neden batıyor Biz baktık Hani
dünyada niye batıyorlar bakın dünyada
%42 diyor ki abi benim bir fikrim var
milyon dolarlık bir fikir ama çalanı
diye anlatmıyorum çıkınca zaten
göreceksiniz başarı olunca sonra
çıkarıyor Sonra Kimse kullanmıyor Kimse
para ödemiyor Çünkü pazara ihtiyacı yok
dünyada girişimlerin %42'si olmayan
pazara ürün geliştirdiği için batıyor
Ondan sonra devamında ne geliyor işte
parayı yönetememek gelir gider dengesini
yönetememek doğru ekibi kuramamak Sadece
bizim değil aslında dünyadaki
girişimlerin yaşadığı problemlerde
Bunlar Biz bunu çözmeye niyetlendik ve
odaklandık
niye teknoloji girişimcilerine
odaklandık Çünkü teknoloji girişimcileri
dünyaya değişecek toplum değiştirecek bu
kesin çok küçük bir örnek vereceğim
Trendyol hepimizin bildiği marka 10 yıl
gibi kısa bir sürede uçuk değerleri
ulaşan bir şirket Aslında Tabi ki ciddi
anlamda ekonomiye dönüştüren
şirketlerden biri birçok rapor diyor ki
bu rapor diyor ki mesela 2023'te
Trendyol iki buçuk milyon kişiye
neredeyse dokunuyor doğrudan İstanbul
oluşturuluyor Yani şöyle düşün iki buçuk
milyon kişi trendyol'da ekmek yiyor yani
konu bu kadar net Bu şirket 50 yıllık 60
yıllık Holding değil 10 yıllık teknoloji
girişi var Biz diyoruz ki nice
trendyolları Olsun getiriler olsun Nice
teknoloji firmaları olsun ki bu toplum
teknoloji ile dönüşsün sektörler
dönüşsün
bu niyetle de üretken Akademi doğdu
Aslında verdiğimiz şuydu Türkiye'nin her
yerinde gençleri bu yolda bizi
destekleyelim
Çünkü bu ülke kalkınacaksa iki dağdaki
Ahmet'le Diyarbakır'daki Mehmet'le
Antalya'daki Ayşe ile Aslında kalkınacak
biz o Ayşe'yi ihtiyaç duyduğu desteği
sağlayalım neye ihtiyacı varsa Biz orada
olalım Peki herkes girişimci mi olacak
tabii ki hayır Belki bizim programlara
katılanların %3'ü %5'i olacak %95'i Ne
olacak öğretmen mi oldu eğitim
teknolojilerini bilerek öğretmeni olacak
Ziraat Mühendisi mi oldu tarımı
dijitalde dönüştürmeyi bilerek Ziraat
Mühendisi olacak doktor mu oldu sağlıkta
Yapay Zeka bilerek Doktor olmuş olacak
bu sayede Aslında meslekleri bugün
ihtiyaçlarına göre dönüş sürmüş olacağız
bu onun üstüne bir de kovid geldi
kuvvetten önce herkes diyordu ki ya
Kadir kardeşim seni seviyoruz yani
Yaptığın işler ortada Hani sevdiğimiz
bir kardeşimmişsin ama ne gerek var
Online'a bizim koca koca salonlarımız
var toplarız gençleri verirsin eğitimi
geçen niye online yani gençler ne
yapacak online Düşünsene bilgisayar
başında eğitim Olur mu öyle şey diyordu
üstüne koyup geldi Hatta 5 yıl önce 5
Yıl artı iki günlüğündeyim bir tek
konuşmalar var onda bir yorum gelmiş çok
konuşmayı beğendim ama ben gençlerin
işte ekran başına eğitim alacağına
inanmıyorum Hayal edemiyorum diyor Kimse
Hayal edemiyordu Biz hayal edemiyorduk
komik tekrardan komik geldi yıllardır
anlattığımız ne varsa gerçek oldu
hayatımızı dönüşürdü Biz Mart 2020'den
bugüne kadar hatta Haziran 2022 kadar
40.000 kişiyi destekledi bu yolda o
yüzden fazla paylaşıma ulaştık bankalar
sağlık firmaları sigorta firmaları
ustası örgütler teknoloji firmaları
sivil toplum kuruluşları Türkiye'de
derdi genç olan ne kadar kişi varsa
topladık dedik ki Tamam abi bu bir
platform Biz eğitim mentörlük Odur budur
sağlıyoruz size gelin bu işi ölecek
değilim
ama 40.000 genç ulaşınca bu hiçbir yerde
durdu niye durdu Çünkü bu 40.000 kişi
zaten bu işe yarıyor merakla girişimci
olmak isteyen teknoloji dünyasında
bulunan girişimcilik kulübünde olan
öğrenciydi ama bizim toplumun
dönüştürmek için halka inmemiz lazımdı
hani biz halkı yenemedikten sonra
vizyonu gerçekçi kılamazdık
Burada da Haziran 2022'de bir abimiz
dedi ki sizin dedi belediyelere inmeniz
yerel yönetimlere inmeniz lazım dedi
yıllarca bize bu girişimcilik
eğitimlerinin her zaman şeyi Biz çok
duyduk kamu zordur kamu ile iş yapmak
zordur kamu yarar gibi gibi ancak dedik
ki biz bu dişi deleceğiz yani halka
ineceksek Bu beni deli oluyorsa Biz
belediyede iş yapacağız kim varsa onunla
derken üretken Türkiye diye bir vizyon
oluşturduk dedik ki üretken Türkiye'ye
Vizyon koyalım Türkiye'nin her yerinde
yerel programlar yapalım Fethiye'deki
bir arkadaşımız İstanbul'a gitmek
zorunda kalmasın üretken fethi ile
burada üretsin üretken Edirne üretken
Trabzon üretken Konya üretken Şanlıurfa
Türkiye'nin her yerinde onların ayağına
Biz gidelim diye dediğimiz bir yapı
oluşurduk Haziran 2022'den bugüne kadar
da 8-10 şehrimizde oluşturduk hedefimiz
2024 sonuna kadar bütün şehirlerimizi
ulaşmak bütün gençlerimize ulaşmak
gittiğimde şunu gördük en başta bizde de
şunu sorgula Ya tamam
ilgili kitle yaptık onlardan güzel işler
çıktı peki gerçekten halktan da bir
somut işler çıkarabilir miyiz bazı
bölgelerimiz vardı gerçekten hani
dezavantajlı sayılan bölgelerde herkes
dedi ki abi bu iş Buradan mı çıktı Bizim
Gençler neler yapmış bazı arkadaşlar
dedi ki abi ben bunları yapabileceğim
bilmiyordum dedikleri an dedi ki Tamam
abi bir salkı gittik halk da gerçekten o
işi yapılacağını gösterdi Sıra şimdi
ölçek demekti şu an derdimiz bunu
Türkiye'nin her yerine götürüp bu işte
yapabileceğine inandım Bu ülkenin
gençlerini desteklemek devamında da
diğer ülkelere açılmak
hatta çok iddialı bir söylenmeye
geleceğim diyorum ki
20-25 yıl sonra bu ülkenin Bakanı
teknoloji firması CEO'su Ben de banka
genel müdürü Belediye Başkanı işte
Kaymakamı yürekten Akademi mezun olacak
Bunun neye göre söylüyorum Çünkü
geleceğin dünyasını liderliğini ihtiyaç
duyduğu yetkinlikleri Biz kazandırıyoruz
biz toplumu dönüştürecek nesli
yetiştiriyoruz derdimiz bu bu iddialı
sözünü de tarihe bir not olarak geçirmek
istiyorum burada biz etkinin dalga dalga
büyüdüğüne inanan bir
ekibiz ekibimiz çok genç ama çok
beslendiğimiz abilerimiz abilerimiz
arkadaşlarımız var o dalga etkisiyle
büyüyoruz dip dalga diyoruz biz daha en
başta biliriz biz iki kişiye dokunuyoruz
o iki kişi iki kişiye dokunuyor o iki
kişi iki kişiye dokunuyor derken üstten
Birbirimize aslında daha da daha da
dalga bu etki büyüyor sizleri toplumu
dönüştürecek genç girişimcileri
teknoloji girişimcilerin desteklemeye
genç arkadaşlarımın yaşıtlarıma da bu
işe girmeyi topluma dönüştürmeye davet
ediyorum teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]